hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and i have
huge
eyes the eye of waifu is upon you
and you will hit that like and subscribe
button down below
my aura is not malice it is nice
so nice you will tap and tap those
buttons before we meet a kitty bug of
doom
okay so that's enough eyework and it's
time to take a look at episodes 84
and 85 of honda hunter this episode was
one
huge discourse of status and the
implications of it we got our first look
at nefertiti
nefertiti nefer kitty nefer kitty
queen of the kitties kite's bad feeling
may lead to a
catastrophe it looks like the queen ant
managed to get her hands
claws mandibles it doesn't really matter
except it does
anyway kite had a bad feeling and now we
all have an evil kitty bug who's the
strongest creature that exists in our
world at this very moment if the new
purple aura is to be believed we could
reasonably have expected that by getting
punched ramot became
super powerful magically but he has
proven through his
absolute and unending fear of neferkitty
that there are more frightening and
awful creatures than
he jumping back to the beginning of the
episode it was wonderful seeing
big old lion boy big old lion
boy who wears liam's traditional getup
of a t-shirt and shorts responding to
low brow easy goading from the ladybug
at his side there's a lot to be said in
terms of status behaviors and reactions
when the phrase
were you scared comes into play that
particular phrase is always a direct
challenge in authority
regardless of who says it and i'm always
curious to see how the receiver of such
a comment responds defensiveness tends
to be the response and it most certainly
was here
and that those challenges occurred more
than once suggest that the ladybug may
challenge him on another occasion
when they're not in such direct danger
challenging a lion is an interesting
decision to make and the fact that she
decided to challenge him
in his own environment was even more so
the pride he has is immediately in my
eyes undermined by the t-shirt and
shorts combo he wears
i think the problem in his case is that
i know people like him full of false
pride despite
not having done anything but challenge
the easiest of those that can be
challenged his decision to go against
the rare humans as they're called was
not a response born of anything more
than empty pride and
empty pride is a theme we encountered a
lot the other obvious one
was ramot who became overly powered and
overly powerful
that he was so ready to take on the boys
despite the fact that the power he
displayed was
equal to not greater than theirs and
that he conveniently forgot that there
were in fact three of them i was glad
for some of the opening thoughts that
began to leak through though of
how he would be able to challenge the
authority of the as yet unborn king
the replay of those images of power and
the re-prioritizing that occurred in
those moments when
nefer
[Music]
appeared was a simply wonderful
navigation and exploration of the
emotions pouring through him
watching that shift from his power being
for his own purposes to the reassertion
of the colony as the forefront priority
and so the giving of his abilities to
the royal guard
i do wonder whether it was more than
just the power involved in their
therapist whose
name that did this the purple aura
situation suggests more than just the
effect of a human specialist if that
makes sense it suggests
that she has some kind of pheromone at
her disposal to help remind everyone
structurally within their colony of
their ultimate goal
the intensity of the eyes the power
involved in her hands and the scale of
her to him as she lay it on his head
i experienced that power and was
genuinely unsure whether she would just
flip his head off or not for me to have
that thought at all suggest that
what was involved was that great and if
that's the case
gone and killed while can i have a great
time so will hisoka who i'm sure will
turn up eventually
we can't have status discussions without
someone who in all other situations has
flaunted his dismissal of them
altogether
meanwhile colt's coming to an awareness
of nen alone in the instant of
neferkitty's arrival and the fact that
he was left to become the side character
was another show of status shifting
he's been pushed to one side which
leaves him in a narratively powerful
position
he was not influential or important to
the colony after his authority
challenged by remote lowered his status
in the eyes of peggy enough that
survival of the fit is kicked
right in for them to leave him alone in
the cave while they searched out
arrowboy
speaking of arrowboy i'm sorry you did
everything you could and you stayed
alive so
long the bloodiness of the rest of the
episode cast everything as though it was
from his perspective
those red tones used as he told
nefarikaty with the secrets of nen made
everything that bit more devastating
that he was speaking at all was kind of
interesting
since she'd used the antennae to access
his brain and stimulate the cerebral
cortex it would have made more sense
creatively or
at least to me let me right hunter
hunter
i'll do it i'll finish it for him to be
thinking the responses and
for him to be beaming out through the
antenna connecting his thoughts to her
like i feel like that would have been an
incredible image if
she could just use someone else's
antennae to just
shove them into a brain and suck out
thoughts through the antennae because
antony
equal radar right radar yeah sure
now that they know how to tell what
kinds of men users they are
his use is done it's a powerful thing to
strip someone of their clothes the level
of vulnerability in that image of him
giving up the information knowing that
he would be killed after the torture
and in fact we know he was alive and
still functionally useful
because nefario kitty told them to give
him to the queen to be eaten
the experience of hearing yourself
saying things to the enemy than knowing
you're going to be eaten that to me
is a horror greater than the concept of
being eaten alone
knowing exactly what's coming and
exactly what you've given up when
your intention was to help with his
final thoughts he's betraying the entire
human race
and he'll die knowing that something
that's bugging me is the idea that these
creatures can be born with men
i understand it would be similar to the
human ability and i i understand why
that's possible
animals are a lot more instinctive than
humans so the access to it would be
greater and so it makes sense that they
have access to
men yes but so much of what gone and
killed did
was training to harness the ability for
their need it somewhat annoys me despite
knowing that the enemies have to be
more powerful for the story to continue
it still annoys me that they're sort of
jumping in at such a high level i worry
that we're going to get into a
goku power effect where all that can
happen is more powerful enemies for
really no logical reason
anyway let's get into episode 85 and see
what happens
next come on yo you've been telling me
this arc would be dark for so long you
totally missed what it really is
a love story this is a romance worthy of
shakespeare once pito tells ramot to
punch everyone and laments how sad it
must be
to be average they head out to test
their own strength and meanwhile we've
got this love story where for the first
five minutes at least of the scene
involving the protagonists or who we
presume are the protagonists because
that's
arguable is a retrospective the only
reason to have such a retrospective is
because we're going to lose someone
important so that was well flagged and
once kite handed gon jing's hunter
license it was obvious where we were
going nefariputo has
the most powerful malicious aura gone
and kilwa have experienced
it was very clear and obvious
immediately that despite saying he
wouldn't look out for them that they had
a use and therefore were there to help
kite failed to treat them as people who
could do what he could and instead
reverted to acting like a father figure
in telling them to run he essentially
sentenced himself to death because it
took his attention away from the
creature he hunted
making him ironically as he had
described to them
prey the kilwa got away despite pito's
arrival suggest kilwa and gone could
always have got away once they knew
the extent of what was after them killa
plays a fascinating role in this episode
in terms of focus and narration right up
until the moment of gon deciding to try
to fight kilwa was in the background
observing
eyes are a huge creative device in this
arc more than any other previously in
fact
i'd argue that if you watch the arc and
only followed where eye lines sit you'd
probably get the vast majority of the
story without any of the audio or
subtitling the fact that kite's hat
shaded his eyes made them stand out more
as if hiding the true expression of them
from the observer metaphorically
it fit because we lost sight of his eyes
at the point that the eye of mordor i
mean
more kitty appeared and took his arm
kite's softness of character was always
a confusing sticking point for me
that he knew jing had essentially sent
his son to meet kite put a lot of
responsibility on someone who had a job
to do
jing sending his son therefore split
that focus one eye on the kids
one on the task despite telling them he
wouldn't and that was his softness and
his downfall returning to jing's love of
games he actively sent his kid to a part
of the game that he knew potentially
would be absurdly dangerous to see if
he'd make it out alive and if gone had
chosen the card route that meant he'd
meet his father immediately the card
that
wouldn't have brought akilah with him i
wonder what he'd be fighting now or if
it would be
jing's head in a cat's lap kilwa's
observer has come up several times over
the course of the series but nowhere
nowhere not anywhere has his love
shown so strongly as his knocking out
and carrying gone step by step towards
safety his first thought wasn't even for
him
it was forgone he had to get gone out of
that environment it was only when moral
and nov
showed up and i have to heavily eye roll
at their existence because they're next
on the queen's plate
it was their appearance that brought
kilwa back to reality
and re-established his own status as a
hunter namely
below the others at least from their
perspective and this is where i question
whether
actually killa is a very effective
hunter
possibly the best because his prey seems
to be safety
not for him but for gone that's what
he's hunting that boy is in love with
gone
the amount he looks at and does foregone
we always knew it but the fact that he
can't even look at gone at this point
because of how beautiful he is in the
light
takashi had a field day with that one
the softness was like the softness of
old movies where they gently blurred the
art
one might call this episode gone with
the wind even the music with its
sweeping strings and epic romantic
themes straight through the episode gave
us a sense of romance within an action
movie a la indiana jones
with nitero's arrival and encouragement
of the boys i'll be interested to see
how natera goes against pito
the boys have the opportunity to learn
to be stronger and to do better but will
any of them still be alive to meet the
boys when they get in and this is only
one of the royal gardens certainly not
the king
what i would really not like to see is
cut corners on this art i would like it
to be long enough that we see the
training and development but also that
we
can see how morale nov and natera get on
against them
gone's belief that kaite is alive will
probably be the prompt to a new level of
strength and that's good
he'll likely need an extra surge of
adrenaline knowing that the next step is
for them to find
enough space for 100 humans sounds like
pitot is going to be going out to hunt
for themselves
what an exciting prospect do i hear
global panic bringing
every prideful hunter to a place they
really shouldn't be because it'll make
the danger worse
maybe i guess we'll find out next time
because that's it from me if you enjoyed
this episode feel free to click here
here and maybe here and don't forget to
hit like and subscribe and apparently
there's a little bell and i'll see you
next time